strongest version of The Incredible Hulk
and history against a guy who could
control the tectonic plates of the
planet but doesn't have unlimited
strength I mean world record Hulk could
break the planet in half it doesn't
really say a whole lot for scar so the
result here is that again the conflict
that they're having the fight that
they're engaging in is shaking the Earth
at its very core not only that because
of the fact that scar seems to be
absorbing the tectonic energies of the
earth basically absorbing the energy
that the Incredible Hulk is putting off
whatever it is that he's stepping on the
ground or stopping on the ground because
remember with each step that he takes it
shakes parts of the planet to the
Avengers to all these over super
superheroes it looks like scar is the
one that's trying to break the planet
apart when in reality All-Star is doing
is absorbing as much energy as he can so
then when his father charges at him he
literally punches or breaker Hulk with
the force of the planet Earth and what
this means is that Earth is not enough
because World breaker Hulk immediately
recovers and pummels the hell out of sky